où et depuis que je suis toute petite
pause 14-6 si on s'enfuit ensemble ce
soir tu deviendras la meilleure de
toutes les danseuses et moi je
deviendrai le plus grand vendeur
enfin rappelant un plan infaillible by
quoi
venu à paris princesse c'est quand la
dernière fois que tu te laver les dents
ça y est je suis danseuse à l'opéra
enfin je suis élève pendant ce temps
g
grâce à votre ténacité et votre talent
sauf vous
dès demain nous commencerons les
auditions chaque jour l'une d'entre vous
sera éliminé tu n'as qu'une adversaire k
vie cette technique est parfait tendue
et le mot perdre ne fait pas partie de
son vocabulaire demain matin
entraînement à 5 heures 5 heures du
matin si l'étoile alors que toi tu ne
brisera jamais
tu dois apprendre à maîtriser
fantastique à
hagard
alors je leur ai jamais ce rôle si tu
l'auras tu as dans le coeur quelque
chose qu'elle n'aura jamais la passion
un garçon il est beau gosse
il dit que je vais devenir une étoile
c'est ce que j'ai toujours dit
danse avec ton coeur
tu fais de la danse ou du kung fu tu es
tellement drôle
photo céline école de danse à l'opéra de
paris re
je sais que tu rêve de devenir danseuse
mais les rêves ne se réalisent pas
voir on s'échappe
deviendra une grande étoile et moi je
deviendrai le plus grand bonheur de tous
les terroirs
un plan un plan infaillible
voici mes ailes de poulet ressemble le
thé bête ou quoi
les poulets ça ne prenne pas bien sûr
que c'est ici
oh
et
il
jamais renoncer à ses rêves